[Music]
hi guys so here the Singapore launch of
the new Samsung Galaxy Note 9 and here
are first impressions so the Samsung
Galaxy Note 9 has a 6 point 4 inch
display it's just your point one inch
bigger than the note it and it comes
with no not just thank goodness the
buttons we have our usual home button we
have our volume and victory button
it comes with a 3.5 mm headphone jack
and USB charging as well as the s-pen
on the back there is a dual camera setup
and the fingerprint sensor which is now
shift up below the camera since the
phone is actually quite big the
placement of the fingerprint sensor
means that is actually quite awkward and
you have to reach a little bit to unlock
your phone especially for people with
small hands the processor is that all
chrome Snapdragon 805 which is the same
as the samsung galaxy s 9 it comes in
two models the 128 gigabyte with 60 by
Ram and 512 gigabytes with 8 gigabytes
of RAM
it's running on the Android 8.1 Oreo and
the battery life has also been upgraded
to 4000 milliampere which supposedly can
last you the entire day
there are three colors available in
Singapore ocean blue midnight black and
metallic copper
the galaxy not 9 sports a new and
improved test and it connected your
phone - blue 3 and just charging it for
one minute let's you use it for one hour
as always you can draw in take notes but
now you can also use it as a remote to
take awesome book classes as a clicker
for presentations or if not you can also
program the button to function with
various apps in your phone that's the
dual camera setup with dual apertures
just like the galaxy s 9 plus the
camera is an intelligent camera that
comes with Auto Scene detection that
optimizes your photos depending on the
scene it also has flaw detection which
gives you a notification immediately
when it detects that the picture you
just talked was blurry or is the subject
blink so this lets you know that you
need to take another shot video
recording is available up to 4k
resolution at 60 frames per second the
huge internal storage definitely comes
in useful here the hangender a gigabyte
version will be
1398 dollars while the 512 gigabyte
1728 dollars both models will be
available in Singapore from 25 august
pre-orders for a phone was stalled from
10 August and 18 and all of those who
pre-order will get a free upgrade to the
512 gigabyte model
overall the Samsung Galaxy Note line is
a solid
that took everything new users have come
to love and maybe even better look out
for a full review coming soon